hey yes we all love each other here is
that all that's not on it's often today
we are in the Tuscan town of Radha high
up in the hills and I'm gonna be driving
around with Jordan and it's really cool
I think late 1960s Fiat 500 this is a
vintage 1962 Fiat Cinquecento it is the
smallest car I've ever been in I think
the size of an American glove
compartment the car is one of the most
gorgeous cutest automobiles I've seen
anywhere in the world
take a look at the exterior and it's
such a representation of classic Italian
romance we know should we not know and
try to figure it out what what's this
how to start the car I guess it's a
vintage car
yeah I don't know well eventually always
if this is my decision
[Music]
apparently the brakes aren't good the
steering is mediocre and there's no
airbag Jordan is going to be driving on
twisty roads and I think he had a lot of
wine with breakfast the Maine this might
be my last appearance please tell my
accountant that I loved him and then I
guess I had family to whatever he'll
take care of that
you